has there ever been a house that you
gave up on you're like I can't sell this
thing there's a murderer or have you
ever sold a house where the murderer was
in there no I've been in houses where
there's definitely been suicide or
there's been a murder inside I can
definitely feel the bad energy the
haunted house does that mean you sell at
a discount you should include Sage with
the purchase most traditional Asians
that's like the number one question
anybody die inside this house there is a
disclosure form that a seller does have
to fill out has anybody died on the
property in the past three years are the
Asians asking because they're scared are
they asking because they want a discount
it could probably be a little bit longer
what happens in the situation where
seller goes I want Kevin Quan to sell my
house and then another realtor just
comes snaking from the back and goes you
should go with me don't go with Kevin
that should happen he sells haunted
houses everybody's real estate I think
the joke in California is like one out
of every six people have a real estate
license which is probably true I think
it's like nine out of 10 Laker Girls
and pro trainers